hey people welcome to the Reuben report
I'm the human filibuster dave rubin and
I've got Vanessa gomez & whitney mixter
with me we got a ton of great stories
for you we're in the midst of a 24-hour
period right now where there is more
speaking then probably has ever been
done in the history of humanity
literally just like five minutes ago Ted
Cruz ended his like 21 hour filibuster
that's a lot of talking even for a
politician and then over in New York at
the United Nations which I also refer to
lovingly as the Legion of Doom they've
been having the the General Assembly and
a lot a lot of talking not much action a
lot of talking so we're going to get to
all that and plenty more including a
diet fries from burger king but let's
start with the General Assembly in New
York this is every year everybody gets
together they put on their suits they
pretend they like each other and they
give big speeches which are going to be
going on all week this really is all
right now at least about Iran and their
new president rule on e and President
Obama is trying to be buddy-buddy with
them and let's take a listen in the near
term America's diplomatic efforts will
focus on two particular issues Iran's
pursuit of nuclear weapons and the
arab-israeli conflict while these issues
are not the cause of all the regions
problems they have been a major source
of instability for far too long and
resolving them can help serve as a
foundation for a broader ease the United
States and Iran have been isolated from
one another since the Islamic Revolution
of 1979 this whose trust has deep roots
Iranians have long complained of a
history of us interference in their
affairs and of America's role in
overthrowing an Iranian government
during the Cold War on the other hand
Americans see an Iranian government that
has declared the United States and enemy
and directly or through proxies taken
American hostage
killed US troops and civilians and
threatened our ally Israel would disrupt
okay so first off I just want to note
that I feel like Obama had just the
right amount of gray in his hair for
that you know they adjust his grade
depending on how serious they want him
to be I feel like they really nailed it
with Alan so rouhani is the new
president they're calling him a moderate
they're saying he's on a charm offensive
right now he also is not denying the
Holocaust like Ahmed in a jot he just
says he's not a historian so I guess
that's progress somehow what do you guys
make of this the overture is going on
here this little dance you know they
didn't meet they said they were going to
maybe meet at a lunch but then it turned
out there was wine at the lunch so rouen
II didn't want to go to a place where
alcohol was being served but what do you
think of this whole idea of putting on a
suit and everybody come in and at least
talking that does seem like maybe that's
a little bit of progress right i mean i
think it's it's it's a it's a way of
just being nice i think there should be
like a guy next to obama band like look
here's the thing your guys or shady is
[ __ ] we know it everybody knows it
that's just what we know but we can't
beat the bad guy and come in there and
just you know because we have a bad
reputation to just come in and storm and
say you got to change everything so
we're like you know what we don't want
to change your operation wheel we don't
want to mess with you we just don't want
you having weapons of mass destruction
and killing everybody so we're just
gonna play nice and then you know is
when I was a kid it was like don't start
nothin won't be nothin like it was like
you know as long as you cool we go home
when you start something we're gonna end
it it's not gonna be good yeah um I mean
it'd be a good name for a phone again I
mean listen they have proven over and
over again that every treaty they go
into they they breach in some way or
whatever I mean not just to us and Obama
pointed that out is like look it's not
even just you know our beef it's like
everybody's beef yeah and you're picking
on you know Islam and that's you know
that's a sore spot for us too so I think
it's just our nicety way of not just
barging in as we may be wood before like
look we're trying to do so what we're
trying to this peacefully we're trying
to you know I think it's more of like a
front like that so that when we do
eventually go in barn we ready
but yeah we were it hard like a you
brought it you know so is that really
what's better because it does seem good
to me on its face it seems good we're
talking again maybe I mean at face value
there's so many aspects of government
can seem great I think though going on
with what you were saying I think that
it would at give added a you know value
if they played the theme song from
colors in the background yeah and right
yeah there's like you know you could get
like hood with it come on let's call it
what it is here like you know I think
Obama first of all the way he delivers
his speech is in general I always wait
for that pause I feel like I'm like
getting low to sleep like why this like
George Clooney of a president yeah what
didn't this speech seemed particularly
posi yeah yeah very slow in this
scenario and there's like a pause before
he says 1979 what's gonna happen I send
you it pans to John Kerry who's actually
sitting there like this like watching
him like like with like a downturn face
well I can't really move his face at
this point so that's not as chair of
what Obama yeah but you know I think the
his approach is very like like you said
like very homey approach very lazy
affair like you know what let's just
call it even yeah screw it you know I
think you did your for sure we do our
fair share let's just you know truth
homie like let's do it but that's what i
mean by progress because we never had an
american president that went to the
united nations sounds like you guys have
some valid reasons for hating us you
know we had bush before this and it was
nothing was ever we just barge Sam
that's what I mean so like soon the the
idea of talking even though they didn't
do the handshake and that's obviously
not gonna happen this week it basically
seems pretty pretty good right like do
you think there's any you know a lot of
Republicans are saying well this is bad
because now you know Rick we're talking
right at least thought about it that's
close enough it's like in a relationship
you're like dude I gave you the benefit
of the doubt you know it baby like you
you're using it just so later down the
line cuz you know you're gonna end up
later it on the line but you could use
them we'll let that car to be like
remember we wanted to talk it out okay
we'll talk
no room welcome to the missiles or
whatever yeah so do you guys both think
that this is that that's really what's
going on here this is just the nice talk
before ultimately something has to be
based on history will be done yeah I
mean it's an idealistic approach I mean
and reality it's an idealistic approach
we have to see how things pan out with
you know who sticks to their word longer
who it's like a waiting game yeah it's a
chess game that's literally what's
happening here yeah so it's like you
know whoever acts first it's gonna it's
going to come to a head yeah well I do
have to say I've been very hard on Obama
lately especially with all the serious
stuff but I do think the talking is sort
of good even if at the end just means
that the smack that much more civil to
do it that way or to at least look there
appear as though we're trying to go the
peaceful route first and then you know
that second yeah we're Americans it's
all about appearance here apparently